Hello and welcome.
In this video we're going to talk about 10 English words.
It didn't exactly quite make the cut into modern English.
Should they be brought back?
You tell me,
but for now here they are.
So the first one we have is cumber.
The word incomers still exists,
but not the Anglo sex in route to cumber,
which can be used as a verb or a noun relating to something which causes
trouble.
Next we have Callen.
Sure.
From the Latin word Kaleo meaning heat.
It refers to delirious behavior associated with intense heat as it is now
September where I live,
we don't really have this problem,
but over the summer it's definitely possible to some people separate from some
calendar or delirious behavior associated with heat.
Next,
we have the word cross tid,
which may be a popular word among college students.
I there were first with time in which one consumes alcohol,
sort of like an extreme tee time.
Next we have booth from the German word vote referring to someone who was
extremely angry and potentially violent.
Similarly,
capra lash is a word referring to abusive or harmful language,
but can also be used to mean a disciplinary scolding or something similar in
less extreme.
Next,
we have purposed,
this word is an entirely gone from English.
It refers to limb,
which can grow crops and produce food.
Good land.
The word has become the modern word birth though in English and it was also
related to the word harvest.
Next we have miss [inaudible].
This is a French word actually from Ms. Paul.
Write the word [inaudible] means to miss.
Take or misunderstand just as it does in its French route.
Next,
we have sanctify,
which means reduced blood.
It comes from the Latin song with,
but it has been replaced by the more modern term to just bleed,
which the word blood is a dramatic word.
Next sofar [inaudible] are medicines that have been used to treat headaches.
Today we use painkillers still for headaches though,
not under this name,
and certainly not in the ways that they used to treat headaches such as bearing
the hair from your haircut as if that would surely stop a headache.
And finally we have the word English and bone,
which means capable of being either translated or made a part of the English
language.
Similarly,
another name for a translator was an English a fire.
These words are once English a bowl.
Can they be,
again,
let me know in the comments section below.
For more videos about linguistics,
I would invite a check out my channel and my linguistics playlist for more
videos,
a much more.
I would invite you to check out my other videos in place as well.
Thank you for watching.